[Musique]
nous sommes
sur le point d'être prêts parce
qu'en fait la technologie et l'application le
monde de toutes ces applications sur nos
smartphones nous permet absolument de
nous libérer enfin de la voiture
mais mais simplement d'utiliser la mobilité comme un service
que ce soit la location  scooters ou
vélos électriques, les villes qui ont déjà un
réseau de rues piétonnes sont les mieux
placées
pour vraiment le faire,
je pense que pour ceux d'entre nous qui ont pu
travailler à domicile,
nous avons soudainement vu une génération
rejeter le trajet
qui  ils ne veulent pas retourner au
bureau ce n'est pas qu'ils ne veulent pas
être entourés de gens ils ne veulent pas
être en ligne uniquement chez eux ils sont un peu
fous à la fin de la journée pour pouvoir
pour sortir
et ressentir un lien avec cette communauté plus large
et cet espace plus grand, je pense que
cela signifie que nous devons vraiment commencer à accorder
beaucoup plus d'attention à la conception de
notre domaine public, en particulier nos rues,
elles sont de plus en plus dominées par
les voitures et à  bien qu'ils ne soient pas toujours très
attrayants, ils sont souvent des
endroits assez moche pour être les
villes réaffectent l'espace
qu'elles mettent leurs rues sur les
régimes routiers enlevant une partie de cet espace pour
les voitures pour mettre des trottoirs plus larges
plus de pistes cyclables  voies réservées au transport en commun
[Musique]
le plus grand défi est si nous nous adaptons au
changement climatique est d'essayer de vraiment
réduire le temps que nous conduisons
et de vivre de manière plus compacte afin qu'au
lieu de maisons individuelles et
d'immeubles, nous vivions
où nous partageons un mur ou un sol
afin que nous consommons beaucoup moins d'énergie,
réduisons nos émissions de cette façon,
donc si nous pouvons faire de
la vie compacte
un choix attrayant et intégrer de nouvelles
technologies comme le transport en commun et les scooters,
mais d'une manière qui nous permet de vivre de manière
plus compacte
et moins dépendante de la voiture